l'un de bonnes choses à commencer par un
emploi car carlos ne trouve pas et ils
cherchent depuis quatre ans carlos 42
ans un chômeur de longue durée qui ne
baisse pas les bras
monsieur toujours portés volontaires
pour
du bénévolat de la manifestation et puis
tout âge je ne sais pas je suis pas
rester isolé nous on garde les bras aux
pour regagner de la confiance surtout la
confiance
carlos s'est porté volontaire pour
intégrer le dispositif territoire 0
chômeurs de longue durée
l'argent qu'il touche au chômage va être
utilisé pour lui financer un emploi en
le mettant en relation avec une pme
locale
carlos gagnera le smic plutôt que de
toucher le rsa tous ceux qui auront un
chômage qui optent pour être présents de
longue durée font un chômage qui
habiteront sur le territoire depuis plus
de six mois pourront travailler dans
l'entreprise avec d'emploi les
politiques ils ont fait leur boulot
non c'est au territoire et à ceux qui y
habitent de faire le leur dans une
perspective d'avenir
après l'assemblée nationale qui a adopté
à l'unanimité le projet zéro chômeur de
longue durée
le sénat examine aujourd'hui
l'expérimentation qui devrait être
lancée en septembre prochain